When you think of a war reporter,
who do you picture?
Someone like this?
Or someone like this?
Maybe him?
Or maybe someone like this?
Her?
I'm asked all the time,
what does it feel like to be one
of the only women working in your field?
How do you cope
in such a male-dominated industry
as frontline war reporting?
The question continues to baffle me.
Women have been doing this work
for over a century.
From Martha Gellhorn
to Clare Hollingworth,
from Marguerite Higgins
to Christiane Amanpour.
In fact, one of the reasons I wanted
to become a foreign correspondent
and a war reporter
was watching these women
in the field, reporting.
They were professional role models,
every evening at 6pm on the news
when I was a little girl
in my living room,
growing up in Northern Ireland.
Women reporting from
all over the world on the BBC,
and the men were listening to them.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
Today when I go to war zones,
very often it is a majority of women
who are actually reporting there.
So when I point out
that I'm no trailblazer,
the next question to come is, why?
Why are so many women
becoming war reporters?
(Laughter)
My answer to this question
is quick and easy.
Because we are really, really good at it.
(Applause)
So good, in fact,
that war reporting today,
the very nature of reporting,
and therefore how wars are perceived
by those we report to,
has been changed by women taking the lead.
The types of stories that are covered,
the angles that are taken
have been shaped by the fact
that more and more women
are reporting them.
The debate over whether or not
men and women are different
in the workplace,
whether we should
highlight these differences,
whether it matters, has gone on for years.
In war reporting,
it hasn't always been a given
that we should lean into our gender lens.
For years, women who have fought
to be at the front line,
to be given assignments in major wars,
often by male editors,
have felt the pressure
not to be pigeonholed
into covering "women's issues"
or "softer topics."
Who here hasn’t felt this way,
uf you’ve ever been one of the first women
in a male-dominated field,
that pressure to be one of the guys,
to not be too emotional?
I was first struck
by the number of female war reporters
when covering the war in Syria.
It was one of my first ever
major assignments for a TV news network.
I was to be smuggled
across the border from Lebanon
into a rebel stronghold in early 2012.
The activists who were
smuggling journalists in
typically took us one at a time.
The journalist who preceded me
was a female correspondent
for "El Pais" newspaper in Spain.
Two journalists came after me together.
One of them a female
correspondent for CNN,
the other a female correspondent
for "The Times of London"
called Marie Colvin.
Colvin wouldn't make it
out of Syria alive.
She was killed by the Assad forces
while reporting on their war crimes.
Yes. This is dangerous work.
When I moved to Beirut in 2014,
the war in Syria raged on,
and the Lebanese capital had become a hub
for international journalists
who were living there
and covering the war across the border.
I was struck by how many
of them were women.
More obviously, of course,
those who were on-camera TV reporters.
But a huge amount, in many cases,
the majority of print reporters as well,
were women.
Walk into any bar in Beirut back then
frequented by international
and Lebanese journalists
and you would have been faced
with a small crowd of smiling,
waving female foreign correspondents
catching up between
assignments and deadlines.
Now while there was plenty of camaraderie
on the assignment in Syria,
the war in Afghanistan in recent years
has felt different.
The US press, as the war came to an end,
was less interested in that conflict
beyond what it meant
for the geopolitics in the region
or US foreign affairs
and national security.
The few times that I did
bump into female journalists there,
the few times I bumped
into any journalists there,
they were almost always women.
One day, about six months
before Kabul fell to the Taliban,
I went out to visit a checkpoint
on the outskirts of Kabul.
At the time, there was already concern
about whether or not
the Afghan forces could hold off
a Taliban attack on the capital.
Shortly after I arrived,
another crew came,
and the soldiers got very excited.
This was a news team from TOLO TV,
and the correspondent
was one of the most famous
journalists in Afghanistan.
Her name was Anisa Shaheed.
The soldiers crowded around,
trying to get a photograph
with her in a selfie.
So did I.
(Laughter)
This sort of thing happened
all the time in Afghanistan.
Women bumping into one another,
reporting on that war.
Between us, we covered
civilian casualties,
women's rights, access to education
and the hopes and dreams
Afghans had for their future.
Of course, we also covered
the major news of the day, the politics,
the frontline fighting and the conditions
for the Afghan security forces.
But we relentlessly interviewed civilians,
profiling doctors and teachers
and business people, many of them women,
elevating civilian voices.
In the early days
of the war in Afghanistan,
while vital, risky
and important work was being done,
very often the kind of images
that were making it out of the conflict
looked largely like this.
As the war came to an end
in its final years,
the predominant images
were increasingly looking like this.
Now, of course, Afghanistan
had evolved and changed,
but so too had those
who were carrying the lens
through which the world would see it.
Now, none of this is to negate
the vital and important work
our male colleagues do in the field.
Male journalists have been
and continue to do brilliant reporting.
But what I want to draw attention to
is the rapid growth
of female journalists in the field
and also the impact they've had
on the reporting itself
that has come out of war zones
around the world.
Now, when wars break out,
it's humanizing images like this
that are predominantly
broadcast around the world
that show how families and communities
are impacted by war.
They're no longer the exception.
They are the norm.
When Vladimir Putin
invaded Ukraine in February 2022,
the images that were broadcast
around the world
were of families saying goodbye to fathers
in Kyiv train station,
children clutching their pets
in underground bunkers
and the elderly clamoring
over broken bridges, trying to escape.
It was these human images
that connected millions of people
to what it was really like there,
for people to live through that war.
Many of the stories
coming from the war in Ukraine
were reported by women.
Earlier this year,
the Ukraine reporting team
for "The Washington Post"
was awarded an award
for courage in journalism
for its huge, female-led teams
of editors, writers,
photographers and journalists.
And who could forget the women of Iran,
who not only are protesting
against the repressive edicts
of their government,
but leading the fight to make sure
the world covers their story.
Every day, women activists
and journalists in Iran
fight to make sure, and risk their lives,
to make sure the images and videos
of their struggle,
their protests and the crackdown
against them, make it out.
It's those voices that I remember most,
filling my apartment in New York City
in the middle of the night.
For journalists like me and many others
who cannot access the country,
we have been able
to make contact with these women.
They use slow internet connections
and outlawed VPNs.
Now, if you're going to report
from a war zone,
female camaraderie does help, too.
When Kabul fell to the Taliban
in August 2021,
I was part of a small group
of international journalists
who decided to stay at the airport
and continue on their reporting
on the evacuations.
Part of that group included
a female producer for British TV,
as well as a female correspondent
for Danish television.
Between the three of us,
we shared everything
from a precious clean shirt
to eyeliner and hairbrushes.
We may have been reporting
from a war zone,
but we all knew
the pressures of being a woman
who had to be on TV that night.
And I know what a lot of people wonder.
What about the tough stuff?
What about the sleeping in trenches,
lugging gear, coming under fire
and the generally rough living conditions?
I get asked all the time,
how do you take a shower?
My male colleagues never get asked.
It seems absurd that we have to
keep answering these questions.
But again and again,
women have proven
that they are just as tough,
brave and stoic
when faced with the physical
and emotional challenges
of reporting from war zones as the men.
Why wouldn't we be?
We've been doing it for decades,
since the Spanish Civil War,
World War II and the War in Vietnam,
even though women at the time
were a tiny minority.
Since those who came before us
nudged the door open just enough,
the number of women
who have been able to in the last 20 years
get assigned stories
as editors, photographers,
writers and broadcasters
in major war zones
has massively increased.
We've not only increased in numbers,
but crucially, we've increased
in our confidence to tell stories
that harnesses our unique perspective
and our own unique strengths.
Now many of the things
we may have feared in the past
would be held against us,
our compassion, our empathy
and our focus on civilian lives
have become our greatest strengths.
We're also seeing that reflected
in our male colleagues' reporting as well.
A focus on how war impacts
communities and families more broadly
has become the norm.
We are not just good at this job
because we are empathetic and softer
and have a really good eye
for a human story.
We're good at this reporting
because we're soft and empathetic
and strong and tough and brave.
We have extraordinary range,
and it is female range that is added
to the range of voices
and stories and faces
that are making it out
and in front of the public
from war zones today.
When the world is presented to you,
not just in television and radio
and print and magazine,
by a male gaze
but by a female reporter as well,
our attitudes to the outside
world change, too.
We feel more connected.
We can see beyond the statistics,
the politics and just the war-fighting.
We as journalists
are at heart communicators,
and it is female reporting
that is helping the world better commune.
Thank you.
(Applause)